vamos a hacer otro problema acerca de
cambios de fase en la materia y de nuevo
vamos a tratar con agua pero espero que
esté estiró un poco más nuestras
neuronas así que vamos a decir que
empezamos con 500 gramos ok déjame
ponerlo aquí 500 gramos de agua de agua
en estado líquido de agua líquida
líquida y vamos a decir también que está
me parece 60 grados celsius am 60 grados
celsius ok ya tengo esta agua y el
objetivo es conseguir que esto llegue a
cero grados celsius la forma en la que
quiero lograr que esto llegue al 20
grados celsius es poniendo hielo a estos
500 gramos de agua líquida voy a mi
cocina y en el despachador de hielo de
la casa pero ojo esta está dando hielo a
menos 10 grados celsius así que déjame
apuntarlo a menos 10
grados celsius el hielo
ok y bueno lo que necesito es agregar
hielo a estos 500 gramos de agua mi
pregunta es exactamente cuánto hielo
necesito o cuántos gramos de hielo
déjame ponerlo aquí lo que necesito
saber es cuánto cuánto hielo necesito y
el lo necesito para que estos 500 gramos
de agua líquida pasen de tener estos 60
grados celsius a tener solamente 0
grados celsius ok ahora imagínate que
tengo por aquí un vaso con agua am este
es mi vaso con agua y por cierto sabemos
que tiene 500 gramos de agua líquida
bueno lo que voy a hacer es agregar una
cierta cantidad de hielo que voy a poner
justo aquí ok tengo aquí a mi hielo a mi
cantidad de hielo que voy a agregar a
esta cantidad de agua que tengo aquí y
date cuenta que lo que va a pasar es que
el calor del agua va a entrar al hielo o
de otra manera el hielo va a absorber el
calor del agua
así que para que el agua vaya de 60
grados a 0 grados de 60 grados a 0
grados
tengo que extraer calor fuera de ella
así que tenemos que decir que lo que sea
que se extraiga fuera del agua tiene que
ser contenida por el hielo y es que ojo
el hielo no se puede mantener por encima
de los cero grados
esencialmente esa cantidad de que no
tiene que absorber todo el calor para ir
de los menos 10 grados celsius a los 0
grados y también esa energía se usará
para derretir un poco el hielo pero si
no tenemos suficiente hielo
entonces el hielo va a ir más allá de
eso y entonces se calentará aún más y
eso es lo que no queremos así que vamos
a ver cómo resolvemos este problema bien
bajemos un poco la pantalla porque aquí
puede escribir
lo que necesitamos y de hecho lo que
necesitamos saber es cuánta energía
necesitamos quitar de estos 500 gramos
de agua líquida bueno que en general es
la misma energía que se necesitaría para
poner el agua líquida de cero grados
celsius hasta
tenerla en 60 grados celsius así que
estamos hablando de un cambio de 60
grados celsius entonces la energía o
déjame ponerlo así el calor que vamos a
quitar es decir el calor fuera fuera
fuera ok del agua va a ser exactamente
igual que y bueno primero necesitamos
saber el calor específico del agua y
para eso déjenme subir un poco la
pantalla porque por aquí lo tengo
anotado el caldo específico del agua y
bueno recuerda que nosotros estamos
picando en el agua en estado líquido así
que bueno estos datos lo saqué del vídeo
pasado y si te das cuenta el calor
específico del agua en estado líquido es
4.178 jules / gramo grados kelvin así
que vamos a sentarlo 4.178 bajemos un
poco la pantalla para seguir trabajando
justo por aquí y lo voy a poner con este
color 4.178 ok y las unidades son
1 / gramo grados kelvin ok y bueno a
esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
cantidad de agua que tenemos pero
tenemos 500 gramos así que 'no voy a
poner justo así a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 500 gramos ok por la
cantidad de agua y bueno a esto habrá
que multiplicarlo por la diferencia de
temperatura pero bueno el cambio en
temperatura va de cero grados celsius a
60 grados celsius o viceversa por lo
tanto son 60 grados lo que tengo que
cambiar y ojo es muy importante que
mencioné que la diferencia es
exactamente igual sean que el bid o
celsius son 60 grados así que lo voy a
apuntar aquí 60 grados y en este caso
son celsius
ok podría ser cualquiera de los dos se
ancle vince o serios el cambio es el
mismo y vamos a ver cuánto es esto si
pongo aquí la calculadora y digo 4.178
178 a esto luego multiplicó por 500 ok
ya esto a su vez lo multiplicó por 60
bueno
el resultado es 125 mil trescientos
cuarenta ok vamos a apuntar esto el
cambio es exactamente igual que 125 mil
340 y bueno esto está dado en jules
entonces esto es la cantidad de calor
que tienes que sacar del agua a 60
grados con el fin de bajarla a cero
grados celsius o dicho otra forma la
cantidad de calor que tienes que agregar
al agua de cero grados celsius para
conseguir una temperatura de 60 grados
celsius pensando en 500 gramos de agua
líquida
ahora bien esencialmente nuestro hielo
bueno pues tiene que absorber toda esta
energía sin tener que pasar por encima
de los 60 grados celsius
así que si necesitamos que el hielo
absorba 125 mil 341 toda esta energía
entonces
ahora la pregunta va a ser cuánto de
hielo necesitamos y bueno y bueno como
en nuestra incógnita favorita siempre le
llamamos x am lo voy a bautizar así
vamos a tener x
ok gramos de diego x gramos de hielo ok
ya tenemos la cantidad de gramos que
nosotros necesitamos necesitamos x
gramos y vamos a tratar de averiguar
cuánto es x entonces qué pasa con estos
equis gramos de hielo bueno pues si te
das cuenta ellos van a pasar de menos 10
grados celsius hasta 0 grados celsius
ojo ahora cuánta energía absorberán
bueno si vamos a ir de -10 grados hechos
a cero grados celsius entonces y déjame
ponerlo con este color si yo pongo el
calor que vamos a absorber el calor
absorbido ok esto va a ser exactamente
igual al calor específico del hielo y
bueno si nosotros nos subimos un poco en
la pantalla vamos a recordar que el
calor específico del hielo es justo este
que tenemos aquí es 2.0 up que me falta
15 2.05 ok entonces bajemos un poco en
la pantalla y es 2.0 5 am vamos a
ponerlo justo
por aquí ok apuntemos 2.05 you'll entre
am gramo grados kelvin ok a esto habrá
que multiplicarlo por la cantidad de
hielo que nosotros tenemos pero cuando
ya lo tenemos
bueno pues tenemos x gramos de hielo así
que a esto lo voy a multiplicar por x
gramos ok y a esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por bueno pues la
diferencia de temperatura que vamos a
tener pero si te das cuenta la
tener es de menos 10 grados celsius a
cero grados celsius bueno pues vamos a
subir 10 grados celsius dicho otra
manera nuestro cambio de temperatura va
a ser 10 grados y lo voy a poner kelvin
porque recuerda que tener un cambio de
10 grados celsius es exactamente lo
mismo que tener un cambio de 10 grados
kelvin con la diferencia de que aquí voy
a poder cancelar los kelvin los gramos
me voy a quedar solamente con jules
entonces esto va a ser igual a 2.05 por
10 eso es lo mismo que ven
punto 5x no olvidemos la equis ok am x
ok
jules así que pongámoslo con este color
jules ahora una vez que estamos a cero
grados incluso el cielo puede absorber
más energía antes de aumentar la
temperatura y esto debido a que se
derrite recuerda que cuando dibuje el
diagrama de cambio de fase a mí vamos a
poner lo justo por aquí si yo por aquí
tengo a mis dos ejes vamos a suponer que
este es un 1 este es otro
bueno pues recuerda que vamos subiendo
la temperatura y después hacemos un
cambio de fase el diego gana un poco de
energía y entonces el nivel a mientras
se derrite esto mientras los enlaces de
hidrógeno comienzan a deslizarse una
sobre las otras y la estructura
cristalina se descompone así que todavía
tenemos en esta cantidad de energía que
podemos absorber y bueno para apuntarlo
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla ok y
entonces si nosotros lo apuntamos justo
por aquí aunque nos va a quedar bueno el
calor absorbido que
va a tener el hielo y déjame ponerlo así
el hielo de 0 grados celsius y esto lo
voy a pasar a cero grados celsius pero
ahora en estado líquido y déjame ponerlo
así bueno pues esto va a tener un cierto
calor que va a absorber el calor ahora
que estamos buscando el calor que va a
absorber es exactamente igual y el calor
latente de fusión del agua y bueno ese
dato lo tengo justo por a camps que
también lo extraje del vídeo pasado que
es justo esté aquí el calor latente de
fusión del agua es 333 puntos 55 yul /
gramo así que vamos apuntarlo por acá
333 puntos 55 am ok estamos justo por
aquí and 333 a 333 puntos 55 llull /
gramo
ok ya esto habrá que multiplicarlo por
la cantidad de gramos de hielo que
nosotros tenemos pero nosotros sabemos
cuánto tenemos del hielo
tenemos x gramos de hielo así que a esto
habrá que multiplicarlo por nuestros
equis gramos ok y bueno esto a cuánto es
igual el calor absorbido va a ser igual
a 333 puntos 55 por equis bueno estos
333 puntos 55 x ok
pongámoslo con este color para no
confundirnos x jules x jules date cuenta
que este es el calor que vamos a
absorber para pasar de nuestros cubos de
hielo o espera aquí me falta un ace de
celsius ok y esto lo vamos a pasar ahora
a agua en estado líquido a 0 grados
también ahora si nosotros queremos saber
en total cuánto calor estamos
absorbiendo ok vamos a bajar un poco más
la pantalla porque ahora date cuenta que
el calor total absorbido y déjame
ponerlo con este color
el calor total absorbido ok esto va a
ser igual a bueno primero vamos a
fijarnos en el calor que nosotros
teníamos cuando pasamos de hielo de
menos 10 grados centígrados a 0 grados
centígrados
y 20.5 x jules donde recuerda que x es
la cantidad de gramos de hielo así que a
20.5 x jules a
voy a apuntar la ok 20 20.5 x jones ok
ya esto habrá que agregarle bueno pues
el calor que vamos a absorber de tener
hielo a cero grados celsius ok y pasarlo
a cero grados celsius pero ahora en
estado líquido y eso era lo mismo que
333 puntos 55 x jules 333 punto 55 x y
jules de lujo ahora bien nosotros
queremos que esta cantidad del calor
absorbido sea exactamente igual que la
cantidad de calor que nosotros
necesitamos absorber o dicho otra manera
la cantidad de calor que va a liberarse
del agua que teníamos a 60 grados
celsius y eso esa cantidad de calor era
125 mil 341 por lo tanto lo que nosotros
necesitamos es hacer am
esto está suma igual a am y déjame
ponerlo por aquí esto quiero que sea
exactamente igual que 125 mil 340 jules
es decir la cantidad de calor que vamos
a liberar o la cantidad de calor que va
a salir del agua que teníamos a 60
grados celsius y ahora bueno pues
solamente es lo único que nos falta es
despejar de aquí a equis si tengo 20.5 x
jules y aquí tengo 333 puntos 55 x jules
si esto no es humo me queda en 300 ok
aquí 350 y aquí tengo punto 5 y x puntos
55 ok 350 y 4.05 x jules ok de lujo y
esto quiero que sea exactamente igual ok
que 125.000 ok 340 bulls o dicho de otra
manera y ahora si ya encontramos la
solución x va a ser exactamente igual
qué
125 mil 340 ok dividido dividido entre
350 y 4.05 ok y es hora de llamar de
nuevo a mi calculadora en traigamos para
acá a la calculadora y hagamos esta
operación de aquí 125 340 esto dividido
entre 350 y 4.05 va a ser exactamente
igual que 350 y 4.0 17
ok lo podemos redondear a 354 punto 0 2
ok 300 54.02 así que bajemos un poco más
la pantalla y ahora sí si quiero poner
la respuesta me va a quedar que x tiene
que ser exactamente igual que 300 54.02
gramos
gramos ok y ahora si ya tengo la
cantidad de hielo que necesitamos
agregar al agua en 60 grados celsius y
de hecho tenemos un poquito
de hielo lo cual nos asegura que en
efecto vamos a llegar a esos 0 grados
celsius y bueno eso me va a dar la idea
de que definitivamente quiero que mi
agua se enfría y esto es bastante
interesante porque si recordamos el
principio de todo este problema nosotros
teníamos 500 gramos de agua líquida ok a
60 grados celsius es decir que aquí
nosotros teníamos antes que ponerlo así
500 gramos de agua líquida 500 gramos ok
y nosotros aumentamos solamente una
cantidad menor de hielo aumentamos 354
gramos de hielo y es que esto no parece
nada lógico porque 500 gramos del
líquido que por cierto es un poquito más
que una libra recuerda que un kilogramo
tiene 2.2 libras y date cuenta de lo
siguiente
estos trescientos cincuenta y cuatro
gramos de hielo que es una cantidad
menor que la cantidad que tenemos de
agua solamente pasó de menos 10 grados
celsius a 0 grados en sus mientras que
el agua pasó
60 grados celsius a cero grados celsius
así que cómo funciona esto la razón es
porque gastamos mucha energía y déjeme
bajar un poco la pantalla gastamos mucha
energía potencial cuando derretimos el
hielo entonces se habla sobre toda la
energía que el hielo está absorbiendo
cuando nosotros pasamos del estado
sólido al estado líquido debido al calor
de fusión que tenemos justo aquí cuando
el hielo de cero grados absorbe esta
enorme cantidad de energía solo
derritiéndose es decir sin cambiar su
temperatura en fin espero que hayas
encontrado esto razonablemente útil
hasta la próxima